ja leute herzlich willkommen servus wir
machen heute eine schwindler liege
latent schießt challenge das heißt nicht
passieren wir an die brustwarze kneipe
stellen zu einem gewissen abstand vom
tor hin drehen und dann erstmal so
dreimal um den ball
probieren an die latte zu treffen der
einsatz der ganzen sache ist nichts
geringeres als unser twitter account das
heißt der verlierer muss dem gewinner
dann seinen twitter-account zur
verfügung stellen und der gewinner darf
dann einen tag lang auf dem posten was
er möchte
okay das bildungsziel die abschnitte
besonders genau auf das wie immer
abwechselnd ein fuß ein hand das
motorische
latte getroffen hat und hört erst 22
jahre alt
keiner von euch nach den schüssen
getroffen als ob du mit drehen nach dem
ersten trip sind alles klar leute sind
des videos nicht zu kurz mit max sich
darauf einigen lassen ein best of five
zu machen das heißt wir machen jetzt
jeder noch vier schüsse und wer am ende
der vier schüsse fünf stürzten insgesamt
die meisten treffer an die latte gemacht
hat ja gewonnen max ist dadurch ein ich
hab kein aber mein linker fuß verknackst
bereitschaft
wenn dem schwesig ist dein kopf das
verdrehte sie toben unten gelacht test
am boden lag auf den himmel so spaß
kommt bei mir daher aufs spiel setzen
gibt manchmal diese drehscheiben die so
ein bisschen außen geneigt sind wo man
sich dann wird man sich raushängt ganz
schnell dreht und die drauf und meine
mama hat gesagt es wäre lustig wie
irgendwie zu drehen ich hab irgendwann
stopp gesagt aber es hat irgendwie
aufklärer sehr weiterhin haft oder
seitdem hasste ich alles oder hab
einfach ein problem mit allem was
irgendwie drews wer mitfliegen
wenn man so eine große runde läuft hat
man klarkommen kann aber mit trifft
ab
laut lokaler käfer steht man vor maxi
wirklich ein käfer und läuft gerade
sinnlos und erlebt ein großes abenteuer
ein förster schutz gibt es dazu 3 x und
linux eingebrochen obwohl ich mitte oben
leute ein
ich schwöre ich schwöre ich ziel nach
oben rechts ich ziehe nach oben rechts
ich alles universum hatten der stellen
knicks los
wirklich gut an
jedes mal nachgerechnet unternehmens ich
glaube ich muss so auf
von hinten wenn du konrad dadurch
entstand eine niere kommen
ich war besser
okay leute meine mutter konnte max